thank you everyone for attending uh my
talk
um Diego Torres Quintanilla and this
talk is about how two Sigma Upstream
that's internal goes to Jupiter lab 4
and 3.5 and 3.6 uh only 3.5 is that so
far but more on more details on that
later
before we start a very important
disclaimer regarding the content of this
presentation specifically this
presentation does not include any
Financial or investment advice if that's
what you're looking for you're probably
in the wrong building or in the wrong
YouTube channel
thank you
all right so what desktop does contain
is some introductions at the beginning
to me to do Sigma or Jupiter wish list
and Quan stack our partner in this work
um it also includes uh
the details on our Partnerships
contributions to Jupiter lab
namely around performance improvements
and real-time collaboration
and we also or I also include why I
think this partnership can be a a model
for small and medium companies to
achieve similar things
all right so as stated let me first
introduce myself
um Diego uh the arrows above explain why
my name might seem so long I like that
both sides of my family are represented
in my name
but also Diego Torres is already named
squatted by a famous singer that I don't
like
um my pronouns are in him I have been an
engineering manager at two Sigma for the
last year and I was previously a
software engineer for five years also at
two Sigma
um also Pi data is very close to my
heart I previously co-chaed pivot in New
York City in 2019 and Global in 2020.
so aside from questions uh for this
presentation please come say hi to me in
the hallway if you're also from Mexico
or if you have fun tips for a covid
bicycle boom Enthusiast or if you're
interested in helping organize Pi data
I'd be happy to tell you all about my
previous very positive experiences doing
so and I'd be more than happy to
introduce you to the current organizers
who by the way are amazing
all right so before we move on I'd like
to explain what my employer to Sigma
does and you know why we care so much
about Jupiter
so to Sigma is a financial Sciences
company we combine rigorous inquiry and
data analysis to solve the toughest
challenges across Financial Services
and very short okay
so two sigma's data scientists spend a
lot of time doing research today most of
our research happens in Python
specifically inside Jupiter lab
every month our internal Jupiter lab
distribution reaches about 500 distinct
users which is about 25 of the size of
the whole company
and of course the heaviest users of
Jupiter lab are the firm's data
scientists who are hard at work solving
those tough challenges in finance that I
was talking about
this means that a lot of our productive
time is spent inside Jupiter lab which
means we really care about every single
little detail of its user experience and
its performance
and naturally all of our researchers are
also always looking for great ways to
collaborate with each other so a good
amount of our internal Jupiter
extensions are meant to help you uh to
help our users share their notebooks
with each other and generally just
collaborate together
um but we're also a medium-sized company
we employ around 1 000 Engineers but
they're basically doing all sorts of
things they're maintaining data centers
building storage systems operating
Services
etc etc etc realistically we can't spend
too much of our own engineering time
contributing to Jupiter
um in the specific case of Jupiter
throughout 2022 we allocated about 0.5
full-time Engineers of those 1000 to
work on our internal distribution of
Jupiter mostly resolving like internal
issues so most of this didn't even go to
open source work
but just like Jupiter there are many
many other open source tools that we
rely on at two Sigma and although they
really help us boost our productivity we
can give too much attention to any
specific one of them in great part just
because there are so many of them
um and so pitching in to contribute to
these projects uh with a small amount of
resources can be very daunting not just
for an individual but but even for a
small or medium-sized company like us
and
um I guess the pitch behind this talk is
based on the premise that I think this
is a relatively common problem
they can make companies like us feel
like a small fish in a vast ocean or a
vast Sea Of Jupiter lab users and
contributors
um but actually if you go check out the
list of sponsors for uh the conference
yes there are a couple uh maybe a few
massive corporations but the majority
are really just small and medium-sized
companies like ours
um and many of them care a lot about at
least one Niche Jupiter feature ratio
but maybe they feel that they're not big
enough to make a significant uh impact
in Jupiter development
so for the rest of the talk I'll tell
you about what I thought was a very
fruitful partnership that helped two
Sigma deliver large contributions to
Jupiter I'll tell you a little bit about
what those specific contributions were
and why we think this partnership
represents a good working model for
other similarly sized companies
foreign
ER in this effort this is Quan stack
Quan stack is a team of developers and
contributors of major open source
projects for scientific Computing these
projects of course include Jupiter so
throughout the last two years we have
been working with them to make
contributions to Jupiter lab
and this has allowed our own Engineers
to focus on our own internal extensions
our own internal problems with Jupiter
while Quant snacks experts focus on
making improvements to open source
Jupiter lab that also the rest of the
Jupiter lab Community
can make use of and enjoy
so before we go any further I want to
give uh proper recognition to our
friends at quanstec these are the actual
developers who put actual hands to
keyboard to do all of the work that I
will discuss during the presentation so
sadly I don't think any of them could
make it to Pivot and New York City
they're primarily based in Europe but if
you see them on GitHub a community
Channel or some other Pi data event
maybe Pi data London make sure to give
them your Kudos if you care about this
work
or if you'd like to know more about the
technical details also please let me
know I can put you in contact with them
I'm sure they would like to talk more
about the details or maybe I can just
point you to some pull requests if you
really want to go into into the details
okay so uh enough with introductions let
me get to the first like actual meaty
part of the presentation which is what
have we accomplished together
and this is the part of the talk that
will be very interesting to you if
you're a Jupiter user and you know you
want to learn more about what's up and
coming in the in the newer versions
um so throughout 2021 and 2022 we
focused on essentially two specific
parts of Jupiter performance and
real-time collaboration
so let's talk about performance first
starting with uh some of the bigger pain
points that two Sigma researchers
consistently brought to my team during
2020 and 2021. so the first one being
that rendering large notebooks is
sometimes a bit slow so if you've ever
had a notebook with like 100 200 cells
you've probably seen this also scrolling
around on such notebooks uh can
sometimes get a little bit slow and
jittery uh you know it works but it's
not it's not a perfect experience and
again we spend a lot of time using
Jupiter
and also in general uh
delays in the UI are disruptive even
when they're small so we're really
interested in really perfecting every
little part of the ux
we also found that these uh I guess
performance pet peeves are not really
specific to us
and it makes sense that you know in
general users want things like switching
tabs being very fast so we knew that the
community would receive these
improvements really well so for example
here I'm showing you uh three open
issues on GitHub which referred to
similar problems to what you uh to what
two Sigma has which other users found
so now that they all have a lot of
comments and long discussions between
users and developers which I think is
also a signal that these are not like
trivial issues to resolve
okay
so when we began our work uh the very
first thing we did was to create
benchmarks for the specific operations
that we wanted to improve so these are
benchmarks that can be run to test the
impact of any PR that is submitted to
the Jupiter lab project
or they can be manually run by the
developer of course
we think these benchmarks are not just a
good contribution to the Jupiter lab
project itself we actually also plan to
use these internally to run as part of
our CI for our internal Jupiter
extensions so if your organization has
similar extensions to Jupiter they might
be a good idea to have to make sure that
you know any any Improvement that we
make that you make to Jupiter internally
does not come with draw vaccine
performance
um and I will explain uh in a little bit
exactly how to read those plots
all right so on to the actual
improvements that were made so the first
one is this thing called virtual
rendering if you're not familiar with
virtual rendering it essentially means
that jupyter lab will only have to draw
the UI elements that are actually
visible in the screen not everything
that is in The Notebook
this is very similar to the infinite
scroll feature that you see in many
social media sites where rendering the
whole like timeline doesn't actually
require loading every single tweet or
post
um
so why did we do this
um because you know after this change
rendering time is now just bounded by
the amount of visible cells not the
total cell count
and this greatly benefits obviously
notebooks that have a lot of cells but
also notebooks that have a lot of cells
with interactive uh with complex web
elements so things like interactive
plots or iframes I think one of the
issues I showed a second ago was about
like notebooks getting slow when there's
many plotly plots that is the kind of
thing that really benefits from this
okay so those plots that I showed you
before uh actually show the results
before and after virtual rendering
um the first one being this which shows
um
how long it takes to open a notebook
with a lot of cells that contain
specifically python code and you can
tell that's kind of a massive
Improvement that's going from four
seconds to a bit over one second
this second plot is very similar it also
shows how long it takes to open a large
notebook except that it has a lot a
large amount of markdown cells not code
cells
um
and these two show you how long it takes
to switch into a tab that has one such
notebook open so you can see sort of
improvements all around this is all a
massive discount to the time you spend
waiting for the UI to catch up uh with
you and your thoughts
okay
but as they say these days a video says
more than a thousand plus so let me show
you a quick video that our friend that
our contact friend Frederick uh shot
it's not really important that you're
able to read what's most important is on
the left he has a Jupiter lab instance
that does virtual rendering on the right
there's one that doesn't you can sort of
see the one on the left it's kind of
already done rendering the one on the
right is I guess struggling but also
like showing like a little bit of
erratic rendering Behavior Uh while the
whole thing actually loads
so obviously that is not great I'm gonna
give it a few more seconds just to give
you an idea
okay
all right uh so moving on to another
Improvement that we made together which
was to upgrade Jupiter uh to code mirror
6 from code mirror five if you're not
familiar with code mirror it's an open
source code editor for web applications
jupyter lab uses code mirror as the
editor for every cell and it's in charge
of this playing basically everything
that users type into their cells and
handles a lot of the complexity around
that so this is things like key binding
Source highlighting and formatting uh
even the VM or emacs key bindings those
are implemented by code mirror so
there's a lot of complexity in that
Library
um and so why did we do this well you
guessed it performance reasons code
mirror 6 is much faster than code mirror
5 it is in fact a from scratch
re-implementation of the whole Library
uh I assume with a lot of uh attention
to Performance
um it also paves the way for code
mirror's new accessibility features uh
to Jupiter so my understanding is that
before these changes Jupiter was not in
really good shape in terms of like
accessibility tests and now you know
it's still it still has a long way to go
but it has really gone from an
untractable problem to a limited set of
issues that can now be resolved one by
one
um and once more once more here are the
Benchmark results that we got for this
change showing that massive uh
Improvement in how long it takes to open
up a very large notebook in both regular
code cells and markdown cells
okay yet another problem that we fixed
uh was what we called a misalignment
between the protocol used to communicate
between the Jupiter server the browser
and the notebook kernel
so in many of these cases the Jupiter
server is really just an intermediary
between messages that go from the kernel
to the browser
the most basic example is when you have
a kernel that returns cell outputs that
maybe contain images or or large data
tables that then need to be rendered in
the browser so that the user can look at
those outputs
so the protocol of communication between
the browser and the server which is
represented here by a green squiggly
line and the protocol between the
browser and the kernel represented by
the purple squared line was very
different and this was forcing the
jupyter server to deserialize every
message sort of translated to the other
protocol and then re-serialize it so not
like a huge issue but it was definitely
impacting the performance of how long it
takes for the kernel to return an output
and then you actually being able to see
that output
um so as part of that collaboration we
simply uh align those two protocols so
that now all Jupiter have all the
Jupiter server has to do is forward
those messages along there's no longer
any uh deserialization
translation or anything like that going
on
um things that really benefited from
this are not just cells that return uh
large cell outputs but also
cell outputs that have Jupiter widgets
that again render complex data in
visually appealing ways
okay one final Improvement uh to
highlight that I'm gonna go really fast
over is uh this lumino2 thing lumino is
the web component library that Jupiter
lab is built on top of uh Jupiter lab is
also the main user of lumino
we upgraded Jupiter lab to lumino
version two in particular this comes
with the removal of a lot of previous
things that were previously polyfills
for ES 2018 now they're using native
implementations and that just came with
like performance improvements all over
the place
um it also has enhanced performance for
some specific components like the data
grid which two Sigma really cares about
okay so that's it for performance now
let me talk about the other area where
we focus on a lot during this
collaboration which is called real-time
collaboration or I will be referring to
it as RTC throughout most of the rest of
the talk
so what is it uh you're all probably
very familiar with it maybe you just
haven't heard the term ROTC so it's
essentially when you have multiple users
all working on a single document in this
case obviously a notebook
think of like cursors showing who is
writing where who wrote which comments
who made which suggestions I'm sure
you're familiar with some office tooling
that does something like this
so let me walk you through very quickly
through three contributions we made
together in this space
the first one being together we
implemented Purcell collaborator lists
so that you can see who is editing a
cell at any given point in time
we implemented a collaborator panel
showing who has made changes to the
notebook across its history
and we also made the undo redo history
of the notebook to be like based on to
be on a per sale basis mainly because
you know you can imagine how chaotic
this could be we had many folks
collaborating in a single document and
Ctrl C being a global a global undo
um but uh there is still a lot of work
to be done in the RTC space a lot of the
end user experience is uh now
implementer it's obviously in early
stages it's still a little bit rough but
like the most basic operations in
real-time collaboration are now uh are
now
um have been pushed uh some of them are
unreleased some of them are released in
Jupiter lab
are going to be released very soon in
Jupiter lab 3.6 which should be going
out uh probably within a time span of
weeks
um however there are some big chunks
missing uh the main one of them is a
comprehensive authentication story
so right now you can't really deploy
real-time collaboration at your in your
organization primarily because it won't
really integrate with any major
authentication systems
but what this actually means is you know
every collaborator will just have this
air of mystery being an anonymous
something uh and you won't really be
able to keep track of like you know who
these people are and what changes they
made and or the changes that they made
safe there's no authentication no
authorization at all
um
so raise your hand if you know what that
word is it's not an animal Anonymous I
don't even know how to say it any
guesses
it's actually
uh one of Jupiter's satellites
um I learned this yesterday
um
there are actually 80 known satellites
uh for Jupiter as per Wikipedia so that
should be plenty for a lot of
collaborators
okay
um so up to this point I've covered
everything I wanted to mention that
should be exciting for any Jupiter user
that you know wants to use uh wants to
use the latest version of Jupiter
specifically 3.6 and Jupiter lab 4.
um now let me talk a little bit about uh
how two segment one stack work together
to accomplish these big improvements and
how I think your organization can do so
too
so first let's think about this for a
second
um
I showed you this number a little bit
ago which is the size of our engineering
organization I'm sure that many of you
thought that I'm a crazy person for
saying that we're a medium-sized company
some of you may be thinking certainly
more than 0.5 of those folks could be
working on Jupiter and the answer is
kind of like we do actually want to grow
that number Beyond 0.5 but the reality
is that once we do that it will still be
hard to have this kind of impact in such
a large project as Jupiter
um really the changes that I just
described require very large uh
modifications to Jupiter code bases some
of them are downright re-architecting
major components of Jupiter
so doing this kind of work actually
requires in my opinion going through two
very steep learning curves there's one
which is the of course the technical
learning curve of becoming an engineer
that is capable of doing such large
changes becoming familiar with the stack
this is a snack that's not super
familiar it's not super common at two
Sigma but you know that's something we
could deal with it's something we could
manage but there's also a big learning
curve when it comes to having the social
and the community connections required
to make this kind of change happen
um
well we know that like you know
improving performance is something that
probably everyone in the community just
wants to you it is challenging for an
organization like two Sigma to figure
out
which of the possible ways in which you
can you could bring uh better
performance along are well aligned with
the community's current goals the
maintainers current uh projects of
Interest Etc et cetera Etc
um so we don't want to spend a lot of
time as an organization building
something that won't be able to get
merged and we also don't want to push
the community to solutions that you know
the community doesn't want we obviously
want everyone to benefit from uh from
the work that we're doing together
um
of course there's always the option of
hiring folks that have that already have
this expertise and it is something that
we have done in the past but trust me
also hiring for this kind of skill is
not easy
um and really if you want to start
contributing now this is not really like
a like a good way to start contributing
now it's kind of a long-term solution
so these challenges are why we think
having a partner like one stack with all
of this expertise already in the ranks
is really the way to go
so let me tell you a little bit more
about how the partnership Works
um if you're familiar with like you know
working with a Contracting firm maybe
you've heard the term uh statement of
work so maybe this sounds like you know
very obvious Diego why are you
mentioning this uh what I want to
mention here is you know there's a
statement of work but it is
intentionally not very prescriptive
about the kind of work that Quan stack
is going to be doing in Jupiter this
represents a really good separation of
responsibilities because at two Sigma we
want to make the performance better uh
but you know we don't want to be overly
prescriptive we know that Quan stack is
best prepared to figure out the best
ways to accomplish that in Jupiter that
are well aligned with Jupiter's own
architecture and well lined with
Jupiter's community
um
we also have a process so that internal
support issues can be escalated from uh
can be escalated from our own internal
like you know employees to open source
with the help of Quant stack staff so we
actually have a mostly reasonable
pipeline now to go from like internal uh
reports in our in our company slack uh
so that you know an internal engineer
can help triage them uh to Quant stack
and then Quan stack can figure out like
okay like make some sense out of issue
maybe have some suggestions in a GitHub
issue and eventually we can have a PR to
address that issue probably also by
Quant stack and that issue over there is
an example of that thing working
um
another detail that might be interesting
is that quantstack helps two Sigma
manage our internal Jupiter deployment
uh most importantly they help us stay up
to date with Jupiter which is very
important for making sure that our
internal users actually get to use all
of all the shiny new things that we
contributed together to Jupiter lab
but here is like the first important
caveat so so far I have essentially
Joseph uh you know set up a working
relationship with a team of Jupiter
experts and they will solve all of your
problems but it's really not that simple
there are definitely some things that
your organization is going to want to do
to make this kind of relationship work
and the most important one is staying up
to date with Jupiter and also I just
said that the experts can probably help
you with that this may require changing
some things in your workflow
so let me tell you a little bit about
how we stay up to date with Jupiter at
two Sigma
and the most important thing that we do
is to make sure that the set of
libraries used to run Jupiter is always
completely isolated from the set of
libraries used by the kernels
um by these by this I mean that you
essentially want Jupiter and its kernels
to be running on completely completely
different environments uh and I mean
like virtual environments or content
environments uh that way for example you
can use one version of Ginger or tornado
in your notebooks even if Jupiter
requires a different version
and you know this may seem silly at
first do people actually use ginger and
tornado or other Jupiter dependencies in
their notebooks and the answer to that
question is an absolute definitive yes
here's a basic example dasc depends on
tornado and you definitely don't want
Jupiter telling you what version of desk
you could use it it's weird it kind of
doesn't make sense it's like if you
couldn't upgrade pandas because vs code
doesn't like it
um
so luckily this is nothing new this is
well supported by Jupiter it has been
for a long time kernels can be created
from things like virtual environments
and content environments which will then
show up in the kernel selector when you
create a new notebook or a console
for example you may be familiar with
this thing called Envy condo kernels
it's been around for a long time it
essentially lets you see all of your
content environments in the Jupiter
kernel selector
we have some internal tooling that is
very similar accomplishes exactly the
same goal
uh most importantly it guarantees that
our users never end up running a
notebook with the same environment used
to run Jupiter because then they depend
on the same libraries and that's a
recipe for disaster for reproducibility
um
the separation also means that two Sigma
and Quantic Engineers can upgrade
Jupiter for everyone at the firm
whenever we want without breaking their
environments which is really crucial to
staying up to date
um so here is another requirement for
this kind of relationship uh to work
it's specific to Jupiter uh we found it
pretty important
so we know that internal and open source
extensions can really boost the
productivity of our users we've all done
this before we find a great extension
that gets us a very Niche feature we
like and we and and it dramatically
improves our experience
you know they can also act as an as an
anchor for upgrades not all extensions
uh
um prepare for Jupiter lab upgrades in
lockstep with Jupiter lab they often
take a while after Jupiter left after
the Jupiter lab release is made
which is really convenient because it
means if you really depend on these
extensions you're stuck on the older
version for another while
so this introduces a kind of a very
interesting trade-off which is being up
to date with the latest stuff versus
specializing your Jupiter build at the
cost of that upgrade agility
so I really I really think that if you
want to make this kind of relationship
work you have to lean a little bit
towards upgrade agility
there's of course always an escape hatch
which is you know also send PRS to your
favorite extensions uh
an organization like one stack can help
you with that we've looked into doing
that but of course it can also get
costly so the trade-off is still always
there you just add an extra Dimension
which is funding
okay
um so
um I think that's pretty much all of the
content so let's walk again over some of
the takeaways of the presentation
so the first one
try the Jupiter lab for Alpha version I
think there's been like
20 or more Alpha releases I guess that's
just how the Jupiter lab project works I
highly recommend you try it
there is also a 3.6 Alpha released in
the Pi Pi as well although that one is
probably going to turn in both are going
to turn into betas probably pretty soon
but 3.6 3.6 release I think is going to
be in the relatively near future whereas
Jupiter lab 4 is probably going to be
more of an end of year towards early
2023 kind of situation but again I'm not
an authority on Jupiter lab releases so
definitely check in with the Jupiter lab
Community online if you really want a
timeline
um
all right another important takeaway
encourage your organization to update
Jupiter lab frequently it is good for
your organization and it is good for the
help for the health of the Jupiter lab
project if everyone is using the latest
version because that way bug reports are
always much more relevant
and of course encourage your
organization to contribute to Jupiter it
is the main takeaway for this talk I
think that the partnership between two
Sigma and quantstack is a great
collaboration model
I'm hopeful that it can be useful for
other organizations
if you're not sure of what's a good
place to start check out the Jupiter
community calendar you can just find it
by Googling Jupiter community calendar
there's also a link there I guess uh at
some point the slides will be available
uh
there are
um weekly team costs that you can join
in that calendar and you know these
calls are open to the public and the
Jupiter lab team is really happy when
organizations can participate in them
and tell them all about their problems
because they want to make Jupiter lab
truly better for everyone
uh even some specific efforts actually
have dedicated talks so for example
there is a recurrent talk a recurring
call just to discuss real-time
collaboration in Jupiter
and definitely consider Partnerships to
you know uh amplify the impact that you
can have in Jupiter lab
um
again one particular effort that you can
always join srtc
and another important takeaway uh going
back to something I mentioned at the
beginning definitely consider
volunteering uh next year for pi data or
other Pi data events like this one
um I highly encourage you
um I have been very involved in previous
iterations and can tell you all about my
very positive experience I'm also happy
to make introductions to previous and
current organizers who I'm sure will
also be very happy to tell you about
their experiences
if you're thinking about it but you're
still not sure here is one very
important piece of information
where while we're all enjoying the talks
the conferences organizers and gnome
focus and James are all thinking how are
we going to make Pi data New York City
2023 happen once it's to step up to the
big roles in the organizing committee
have we met anyone that could help us
next year that could be you if you're
not sure you know there's no harm in
asking definitely get involved
and finally uh two Sigma is hiring the
team that made this specific
collaboration it's a software
engineering team is also hiring if this
work sounded interesting to you and
you're curious about Jupiter development
at a financial if you're curious about
what Jupiter development at a financial
tech company looks like come talk to me
or shoot me an email it's just Diego two
sigma.com
or if you're curious about other
opportunities at two Sigma check out
twosigma.com careers
and that's all everyone I'm happy to
answer any questions you may have
especially about how our relationship
[Applause]
just so you know volunteers get to
attend the conference for free so that's
a really great reason to be a volunteer
but you know you have to volunteer for
at least half the time
thanks I have a question
about your last life are you hiring
people at two Sigma to work on Jupiter
and will their contributions be open
source somebody can actually get paid to
work on open source code yeah so uh
organizations like to Sigma contribute
to open source all the time there are no
promises on like you know what
percentage of your time is going to be
dedicated to open source but with there
are frequent contributions to open
source coming from two Sigma and that's
I think our Engineers do that's
basically a dream job for anybody
because
yes what kind of internal extensions do
you guys for sure
yeah sure so the question is what kind
of internal extensions do we have at two
Sigma uh so most internal extensions
these days revolve around
um the way we are able to like share
notebooks internally with each other so
obviously we have like internal storage
systems uh that are not like you know
commonplace in if you're running jupyter
in your own machine they mostly revolve
around that uh we also have actually a
set of Open Source extensions called
Beaker X they mostly revolve around uh
specific widgets for uh for rendering uh
tables in in cell outputs
so definitely check out that is called
the be corrects table display it's just
a very sophisticated way to show to
render something like a pandas data
frame in cell outputs in a paginated way
that you can copy paste into you can
color like you can manually color like
specific cells yeah
yeah Thomas on performance when you have
to align the protocols between the
browser and the distributor integration
kernel you have to take one of the
protocols
oh uh that is an excellent question I
don't know too much about the details on
that one uh but I can definitely put you
in touch uh with the with the developer
that did
yep
I know you're not uh dedicated Jupiter
but to your knowledge after
um performance and real time
collaboration what is the next priority
for this uh for the Jupiter team I
really don't want to speak for their
priorities but what I can tell you is
that uh you know probably two Sigma will
continue to focus a lot on performance
related issues
um I think also
one particular interest of me we haven't
crafted like a like a long-term plan for
Jupiter for the next year yet uh is the
way our kernel manager works I think
could do could be a little bit better so
we really want to look into like you
know how to plug in custom Kernels at in
Jupiter
cool there's oh James do you require
your users to use Jupiter or are they
free to use that among any other tool
they want to use excellent question so
actually so two Sigma is pretty liberal
as to what its uh data scientists are
free to use uh
granted for notebooks the vast majority
of researchers using notebooks are on
Jupiter but you know people are really
free to choose the tools that they want
we do know some users use vs code to
work with notebooks I'm personally also
excited to see like another open source
project uh developed into like working
with notebooks uh but yeah we're we're
happy to see our users like you know
really take full advantage of the open
source ecosystem
yep so it has has real-time
collaboration made Version Control any
more complex
for notebooks oh
um excellent question I'm not really
sure
um but it's actually something we can
forward along to to the team
oh
yeah
do you guys have like a central Jupiter
Hub sort of deployment that everybody
uses uh we do have a like an internally
hosted Jupiter instance but the vast
majority of our users actually use
Jupiter in like a in like a similar way
to what you would do in your personal
laptop where you know they just run it
locally on their on their development
host we do have like you know some
control over that environment that
they're running from they don't really
like you know they don't do conduct
create and then condo install Jupiter
that's sort of done for them we just
have an environment that they can always
use to launch it
so
um I think the first goal for real-time
collaboration internally would be on
like the hosted solution but yeah I
think like you know it shouldn't matter
where it's running uh really
uh real-time collaboration is also meant
to support like you know when you're
running it uh locally there should be
people that are able to connect actually
authentication can maybe get a little
bit tricky in those cases uh
but yeah like I said the authentication
story is still yet to be written
yep Thomas
like four people on a notebook yeah so
um
the reason we started real-time
collaboration at the sigma is that you
know data like our data scientists were
asking for it I think you know to some
degree it's kind of like hypothetical
like you know there haven't been like
many uh I guess there are some cases uh
now of like real-time collaboration and
notebooks in other notebook products by
other companies uh but I think when the
initial asks were made uh like that
didn't exist so the way we see it
internally it's it's still a little bit
experimental we're not really sure like
we know people hypothetically wanted we
know probably some of our internal users
have tried the other Solutions and you
know they still seem interested uh but
really like you know we haven't seen
that uh you know uh letting it out in
the wild and seeing what people think
but I know the Jupiter lab folks
recently did a very extensive test or
the Quantic folks did a very extensive
test with another client of theirs that
is very interested in this in this kind
of work uh so I'm pretty sure they have
a lot of input at this point
um I see a question over there um
uh yes there definitely have been uh I
have not been keeping track of that
specific PR but there is definitely
concrete work that's been done so far to
enable commenting
um I don't know yet if it's been rich
and I don't know yet if it's gonna be in
Jupiter lab 4. yeah but I was actually
fishing for that PR yesterday so if I
find it uh come and find me I can pass
it on to you
yep
you think the other question may be one
option that might help is it the code is
Real Time collaborative of the
explanations are separate yeah
um so I think what's in scope right now
is like you know also the execution but
it's a you know it's an interesting
question
um I don't know if it's if it's in try
cool uh I'll be around if anyone has any
more questions and uh if you're
interested in any of the other things I
mentioned during the talk like hiring
[Applause]